this month the federal aviation
administration reported a huge spike
in the number of unruly passengers
aboard airline flights
this is incredible check it out thirteen
hundred cases since
february that's more cases than the last
decade
combined yeah something's going on
now most airlines will not accept
disruptive passenger behavior
but this new airline not only accepts it
they encourage it tired of the nanny
state telling you how to fly
get over to luff airlines we've got no
mask requirements
seats that go all the way down unlimited
alcohol service
and bring any therapy animal you can fit
through the door
the world is full of aggressive pricks
that's why we ripped out the last 10
rows of seats
and put in the same octagon they use in
mma fights
and it's why we only hire captains who
sound like joe rogan i just turned on
the seat belt sign
if you're into that [ __ ] get 25 off your
fresh flight if you fall into any of
these protected classes
some people think we're just a spirit
airlines plane that got repainted
but we're totally legit love airlines it
stands for lighten up
face the only reason we'll kick you off
the plane is with being a wuss